[Musique]
avec plus ou moins 480 châteaux
implantés en centre Val de Loire c'est
l'Indre-et-Loire qui détient le record
avec près de 154 châteaux c'est donc
naturellement ici à Amboise que ce sont
implantés les parcs et mini château mini
parce que ici on est en mode chérie
j'irai si les châteaux mais pas
n'importe lesquels les châteaux les plus
prestigieux de la région ici tout est
miniature enfin tout sauf Aurore et
Patricia qui s'occupent des parcs des
jardins fleuris mais également des
maquettes mais par contre pourquoi moi
je suis rétréci là pourquoi moi je suis
tout petit et je mesure 1m80 à la base
égoïste égoïste égoïste égoïste tu viens
me rejoindre Kamini égoïste pourquoi il
dit égoïste
[Musique]
bonjour Camille bienvenue dans le mignon
roue libre j'arrive vers toi tu es un
seigneur un chevalier qui va au combat
très bien comment on fabrique ça mais un
milliard comment vous faites je dois le
tailler 4 à 5 fois l'année et on parle
de d'une cinquantaine de châteaux ici
reproduit en maquette dans le mini parc
exactement 41 maquettes 40 châteaux
reproduit au a25e on y trouve quoi dans
mini parcs
on y trouve inacquettiste Patricia
Patricia alors c'est parti
[Musique]
belles fleurs là tu as du Pétunia
tu as de la sauge aussi également
il y avait un château allez on y va
[Musique]
je suis le Seigneur Camille j'adore
votre tenue votre accoutrement aux
cheveux c'est magnifique bienvenue
c'est comment
à bientôt Béatrice j'aime beaucoup
[Musique]
voilà
je te présente Patricia
pourquoi
on entretient un mini château c'est
comme les vrais châteaux la toiture les
fenêtres les petites choses les petites
rambardes qui tombent ou qui sont
touchés et ensuite effectivement les
petites pointes c'est toutes des petites
choses qui effectivement sont abîmées là
je vois il y a un château là je sais
qu'avant il y avait un petit train et
puis alors je sais peut-être une des
petites maisons qui faisait partie
justement au niveau des petits trains
qui circulaient sur le parc ah qui
circule parce que les petits trains ils
ont enlevé les petits trains
mais il y a plus de titres voilà
[Musique]
il y en a plus